what's up everybody welcome to another
YouTube hangout super excited to be here
I have a special guest with me mr. dan
pena known as the 50 billion dollar man
because the people who he has coached
have went on to create 50 billion
dollars plus in wealth for themselves in
the world he is a coach he is an author
he is a speaker he's got a speaking tour
right now he is sometimes controversial
so we'll see what we get into today mr.
dan pena welcome aboard thank you for
having me it's nice to see your face
other than on a website in more or less
in person thank you very much for having
me I love it so for the people who may
not have heard of you yet we've done
some videos on you but for the people
who still don't know mr. Denton Pena a
little bit beyond the intro I gave you
how would you introduce yourself what do
you want to say well I'm a a barrio bad
boy came from the barrio beast' Los
Angeles as a adolescent gotten a lot of
trouble who got flunked out a university
three times arrested five times went off
and the military made amana me in fact
today the very special day 50 years ago
today one June 1967 by an act of
Congress of the United States of America
I was deemed an officer and a gentleman
a second lieutenant so if I write I was
a high performance thing that I ever
achieved because I didn't think flunking
out of school and getting arrested to as
much of an achievement although my
buddies thought it was cool and that's
why I tell kids show me your friends and
I'll show you a future I went on came
back from the military came back to
school graduated with honors ultimately
finished Poirier a degree in two and a
half years went on had a scholarship to
go to law school and every used and went
on to Wall Street and the rest is more
or less history and the I've created
since 1993 my 24th anniversary that was
last week
when I gave my first seminar and my kids
like you have created over 50
dollars in equity and value in those 24
years and I was just on the phone with
one of them who has created billions and
he wishes you all well and he says
you'll need it under the whip
I'm the width and yeah and the I just
started a tour in the United States and
Canada and I'll be visiting your
hometown in a few months where I go to
speak at universities for free pro bono
they don't pay for me to get there or
anything like that they don't put me up
in a hotel and I got the idea Evan when
Oxford University called me last year
and I specifically said oh it must be my
world scholarship 50 years late you know
but I went to speak there and it was a
very successful event and then I got the
idea well I mean if Oxford liked it
maybe a lot of other people would like
it but I was booked up all the rest of
the last year and so I only started
giving these talks to schools but
everything I have on my website is free
99.9% of all the kids that I've created
the 50 billion with I've never met
because all my products free I don't
sell anything other than this the castle
seminar and then I meant to you for a
year free but I've there there I mean
the great thing about today is you know
information is almost instantaneous
actually it is instantaneous like this
work you know you're in Canada and I'm
in Scotland and we're able to do a show
like this so and I think it's terrific
and I take my hat off to you I love it
so let's get to the topic I always have
my guests pick the topic
I don't really cover politics a lot on
this channel you know I always feel like
entrepreneurs we're the ones is going to
solve all the problems of the world not
to rely on the president or the
government are not to blame the
president for your not having success
right like I'm not a success because of
Trump or because of Obama or because of
anybody else I think is ridiculous
and so this is interesting to cover
politics on this channel I'd love to
know why you picked this topic and what
your thoughts are well on November 8th 9
ounce when he was elected now I'm
focused closure
I knew President Trump in a different
life I knew him in the late 80
early 90s when I was partners with
people that he knew in New York but I
haven't seen President Trump in 25 years
so okay but on November 8th I said that
this was the greatest transformation of
wealth in the history of the world since
World War two and the reason why he was
elected in my judgment and I was one of
the first to endorse him publicly is
that the United States is fed up you
know I'm not here to talk bad about
Obama although I didn't think he did
much but anyway and was fed up and just
like brexit in the UK and various other
votes but I know what he's capable of
both good and bad and I know the most
people listening here that are if
they're US citizens have no idea what it
really means if we get a from 35 to 15
or 20 percent corporate tax rate you
have no conception what that means I
mean in a trickle-down effect so I mean
the the Trump era and he may only stay
in one term but the Trump bearer he's
already made tremendous changes and for
if he's done nothing more than we can't
have change if the people rise up we
can't have change if the people rise up
now as another aside I knew the first
Trudeau back in the day probably before
you were born I and I had the pleasure
of meeting him and just as I also have
met five presidents five secretaries of
state and I also met as a little boy a
general DeGaulle so when you've been
around a million years like I have the
you met a lot of people and that's why
the perspective that I give and I
believe why I was so successful at
Oxford and I'm going to be successful at
these other schools and that's why the
kids come here my demographics for this
seminar evan has changed ten years ago
was mid 30s to late 40s the demographics
for the seminar now is late teens to
late 20s hmm late teens to late 20s and
why the shift
two things I believe one the kids can
make money on the internet to pay for it
although we give students at big
discount and we give Miller active-duty
military a big discount that's number
one and number two they know that
they're pissed off earlier now they know
they're not happy and people only make a
change for two one or two reasons you
know inspiration or desperation and to
come to me because I'm really hard to
come to me you have to have tried
everybody in there dog you have had that
I've had kids come here they have read
700 books and in 700 books they couldn't
figure it what the [ __ ] to do so they
come to me and the most important aspect
of my coaching teaching mentoring is the
one-year free mentor program and I give
it free because I want to be able to
throw you out if you don't measure up
and I take exception to people that say
it's a boot camp most of these kids have
never been to a [ __ ] boot camp they
would know a boot camp of a bitumen in
the butt and but I mean we're hard here
like the kids to can't go to the
gymnasium until they earn it I have two
gymnasiums here at the castle they you
know I mean it's it's it's like it's
hard but I find life hard and and the if
you look back upon the Elon Musk's etc
of this world the curtain day they're
tough guys they're not you know
Lissa's you know they're not snowflakes
I think is the word I had to look that
up I wasn't sure what that meant but
they're not snowflakes and most people
come here I'm told because I'm the alpha
male dad modeled that they never had I'm
not asking for any kids I got three
lovely children I don't need any but one
of the reasons that I have admiration
for President Trump look at his kids
they should be spoiled brats now I'm not
saying they're not spoiled a certain way
but they're got their heads on the
shoulder that got their own business the
my kids should be spoiled brats but
they're not they're successful on their
own I didn't get any of my children jobs
I did make one phone call and they went
to good schools your
have to go to school we have kids that
come here that didn't get out of high
school the point is that I make you
accountable I'm the only that I know of
and you correct me if you know anybody
else that makes their seminar attendees
and post the seminar for one year to be
100% accountable 100% not 98% through
the weekly reporting and their monthly
zoom calls that and the it's it's it's
very much like the military and the only
thing is I don't hit them anymore
in the 90s I hit you now I don't I still
like to hit you but now for obvious
reasons everybody's got an iPhone
although we don't let you have your
iPhones in the room but anyway be that
as it may
right now there's a whole room full of
them sitting over in the main castle
waiting to come and we give them a
beatin or a beatdown
and we've got some Canadians the
Canadians love me I don't know why why
they should I normally I don't have
anything good to say about Canada but
other than I've made a lot of money
there and yourself who's been kind
enough to talk about me over the years
in like my 10 secrets etc the I think
it's a very unique concept that you have
and I think you bring in a lot of
service to the kids but at the end of
the day they've got to take action they
can watch all the youtubes podcasts from
now until they're you know they bury
them and if they don't take action it's
all BS the Dalai Lama had his 80th
birthday last year were you invited by
the way I was not invited well I need
neither was i but some of my high
performers were and at the end of his
speech he says meditation is great
prayer is great contemplation is great
but if you don't take action action
action all the rest is wasted and what
the kids today have trouble with they
Cano reading a book to take an action
all and I'm not saying you shouldn't
read because I've read the classics I've
read Shakespeare and you know all that
stuff
but it's not taking action taking action
is pulling the trigger going out and
making something happen and even if you
fail and the kids have problems with
that and they come to me and I show them
the way through the maze as it were how
to learn how to take action so let's
talk about that you got the guys reading
700 books you got people just watching
video after YouTube video up to YouTube
video but they're not doing anything
they show up to you how do you get that
person who read all the books that
hasn't pulled the trigger to do
something well first of all they paid me
a whole bunch of money to come here and
there's no refunds I mean so they're
painting a lot of money and I shame them
I embarrassed them even yourself high
performer and by the way I call
everybody kids because I'm either old
enough to be your father or grandfather
a kid like you if you had to keep track
of seven days a week 24 hours a day what
you do you would be shocked astounded
overwhelmed or as they say in Britain
gobsmacked how much time you waste and I
make them keep track of every minute of
the day every minute of the day and it's
not easy it's not easy and when you find
it out the I have people that have come
to the seminar it's spent 20 hours a day
walking in the fresh air in meditating
20 hours a week excuse me not a day 20
hours a week and they don't get anything
done and they don't feel relaxed now
I've never meditated one second in my
life I've walked in the fresh air but
unless I'm sweating and I'm running up a
hill I don't think that you know I'm
accomplishing much from a cardio point
of view at my age I should be strolling
up the hill or not even going up the
hill so we make them accountable we give
them the templates we give them the
tools for those that even
700 books to read seven books or 20
books you read about all the various
financial instruments but here we teach
you how to play the entire financial
orchestra for the first time money is
almost free the last eight or nine years
yet it's hardly I find a snowflake that
has done anything about it
free the money is free right now 10 20
years from now having the guys on this
call are going to their kids and
grandkids are going to ask him what the
[ __ ] did you do during when the money
was being given away free dad granddad I
did nothing I just kept my finger up my
ass and read another book I mean we're
not going to you know I'm not I don't
know how much longer this is going to
last free money but right now there are
so much money out there it's
unbelievable what the problem the kids
have when they come here and not just
them they come here they don't know what
a real deal looks like they really don't
know that free cash flow has to cover
debt service they don't understand that
concept and they come in here with PhDs
MBAs they're certified financial
analysts you name it we've had in here
and they just don't understand as I say
they would know I deal with a bit of in
the butt and they spend most of their
time on deals that intellectually are
sound good but financially they're no
good and so once you once you learn the
difference between a deal and not a deal
and once you learn for real and we show
you the templates to use the how to get
the money out of the bank's your life is
never the never the same it's just never
the same and why now so you say free
money right now it's not going to last
next generation what's so special about
right now where it's really are so damn
low
I mean interest rates are giving her
away I mean I was making money millions
when interest rates were 15 18 20 % not
2 3 4 % I mean they're literally the
only thing they're not doing is setting
up like the Bank of America founders the
picture you've got in the back
he said up if I remember correctly after
the great fire San Francisco fire of
1906 or five whatever was he said I'm a
card table outside the bank or what was
left of the bank and were making loans
and people still didn't even come up to
him he didn't even do all the paperwork
like now I mean I Oh God I take a jet
plane to die be that number one in line
to do business with that old-timer but I
mean it's it's not that easy but I mean
it's really another thing in America the
Small Business Administration the SBA
recently in recent years has gone from a
1 million dollar limit to a five million
dollar limit meaning the government
guarantees your damn loan and there's
talk under Trump I don't know if it's
you that it's going to go to 7 or 10
million if you I mean if you can't do a
deal when the government is going to
guarantee 100% of a goddamn thing you're
going to blow your brains out you ought
to commit seppuku I think it's called as
Elon Musk said he would rather commit
seppuku purchases Harry Caray then fail
and I mean it's I mean there's a you
know I don't know how long it's gonna
last I don't but I do know that it's
here now and God Almighty I don't know
why you wouldn't want to take advantage
of as long as it's moral ethical and
legal moral ethical and legal those are
my only backstops because I get it yeah
but if you don't want to be morally Oh
God Almighty it be the Mafia I like that
you know your history most people have
never heard of AP Giannini and be able
to pull that story I was great it was
that you cross two barrels two barrels
in a plank of wood and he would make
money he would lend money to people
based off of a handshake and a look in
their eye that's how you got to deal
with AP Giannini he wanted to judge a
man by the calluses on his hand that's
how we made a decision with us give a
loan or not so far partly all they have
the fingertips maybe from the VN on the
laptop let's talk about that so I mean I
got any peach anything behind me I love
learning from successful people trying
to apply to my life my business
I see behind you you've got this giant
wall called the influencers and on there
you have some controversial figures
you've got I saw Winston Churchill and
Jesus Christ and JFK yep Adolf Hitler
Einstein Trump Ted Turner talk to me
you're pulling from a wide range of
people who are ghosts um I've got Stalin
I've got Walt Disney Jack Welsh UNAMI
McNamara from the Vietnam era who
actually knew but all those people now
when they ask me what have I read I read
them ha
what did I look at last night to get
fired up for today for tonight I roll I
read the red I watched the
two-and-a-half-hour movie 1963 movie
Zulu when Michael Caine uh which
depicted 1779 I believe Africa the
British Army were they far off 5,000
Zulus 150 guys and they did heroic stuff
that's what fires me up because it's
tough to keep your energy high and fired
up because I've done just about
everything known to man
I have not all good [ __ ] but I mean I've
done just about everything the known to
man but the reason I have these people
is because I learned something from
everybody you know the Hitler believed
in practice practice practice he had
over a million photographs of him to do
his promotional stuff when he was
selling mine comp anyone he was selling
to become Chancellor of Germany in the
30s a million pictures he was the first
guy being advised by gurbles
that you know if you're going to
influence the masses I studied when I
was learning
was a poor speaker 30-plus years ago I
studied JFK I study Winston Churchill I
also studied Hitler his mannerisms but I
couldn't understand what he said and I
studied to get to be a world-class
speaker that I am today or at least I'm
told I am today I study Harry Truman
who's up here who was the president that
took over from Franklin Delano Roosevelt
when he died in office and he was the
guy that made the decision to drop the
atomic bomb bombs can you just imagine
the heaviness of that decision the
heaviness that you're going to kill god
knows how many people I studied in
current day I study a secretary defense
a general mattis Mad Dog Madison I have
some friends from my military days that
actually know the secretary so I but I
these are all high profile people you
may not like them but they're high
performance people every single one of
them
every single one of them and quite
frankly in my judgment 85 to 95 percent
of the people that write books aren't
high performance
they're also rands why did the kids read
them Evan because they say it's easy and
I mean high performance is anything but
easy
and staying on tops even harder than
getting to the top now I've been on the
top of my game arguably for three and a
half decades
I haven't had to work in 35 years people
ask me how do I get up in the morning I
get up fired up I'm fired up I've been
high on life since 1974 that I thought
about it and actually since I got out of
cs50 years ago today where failure is
not an option
and I do fail but when I do fail I am so
[ __ ] over I can't believe it
it must be an error there must be a typo
because I'm so used to winning and I've
had
the the pleasure the good fortune to
have been mentored by some real real
world world world class guys and and the
world class guys like me oh and they
often say you have the energy I had 50
60 years ago this is when I was younger
and the and you know I went with the
action was I went to New York
they said that while she to eat me alive
barrio bad boy and they were wrong and
the III run towards the gunfire and I
kill everybody metaphorically speaking I
look for problems I look for the because
from chaos comes order from chaos comes
order and I've done that successfully
for 50 years and I'll be 72 in a few
weeks
I don't feel 72 I don't believe I look
72 and I've had if you've noticed on my
websites I'm called a bionic man because
I've got so many artificial parts in me
my knees my hip my shoulders my
collarbone my right bicep
I mean I'm running out of parts to
replace and that's because I do
everything to the maximum and I do a lot
of physical stuff more in the past and
now where I got hurt a lot I got busted
up and but that you know I'm looking to
be all I can be every single day I mean
there's no question and that and getting
back to your original question how do I
change their mindset it's because I
require the kids to be all they can be
every single day for one year I change I
have a hundred percent track record for
changing lights to the better is much
less forbidden errors it's more for
hundreds of millions and more even at
the tens of millions and if I can make
you a millionaire I have to blow my
[ __ ] brains out but I mean a million
the average little dumpy house in a
mirror in Los Angeles it costs a million
bucks now I don't know about Canada but
get in there it might be expensive when
I when I'm in Toronto I'll probably stay
at Trump Tower which I stayed there last
time I was in Toronto not because the
president Trump and I don't know how
close that is at the University I don't
know and I'm making two speeches in in
Toronto one to a group of lawyers I
think financial excuse me financial
people and one to the university and I'm
looking forward to it the so I'm
expecting different kind of questions in
Canada than I normally get I look at one
guy on the back ear wall you got Ray
Kroc who's the guy who built McDonald's
and he really started that in his 60s
and at an age when most people are
thinking about retiring that's when he's
just getting started to go off and build
this huge empire people look at you guys
72 years old still tons of fire sale
tons of energy what is it that gets you
pumped up to continue to do this I mean
you got your Castle you've got all the
material possessions you want why do you
wake up every day and do what you do
because I'm glad you asked that question
because I want to take as many of you
across the goal-line before they put
dirt on me my wife says I have a bad
back because I'm carrying all you
[ __ ] for 25 years okay I went to cake
as many of you across the goal-line and
that's why I give all my product away
for you because I want to take the last
excuse I went from the most expensive
product high performance coaching
product on the net to free and I got
calls from guys that you know their
names
some Canadian what the [ __ ] you're
killing us Stan why are you doing that
because I'm not doing it for them and
everybody's got the right to make a
living I don't want to take that away
from them but if you can find anybody
even done remotely what I've done that's
coaching I'll quit today if you can find
anybody that even remotely has made the
kind of money that I've made for others
I'll quit today nobody talks about
numbers Evan because nobody's created
any numbers and I know it's ghosts and
money is not the only thing in life and
I realize that if you want to save the
world go make a ton of money like Bill
Gates and then save the world like a lot
of the big guys they're saving the world
now some say Evan because they're paying
for the sins that they committed
creating that wealth now I'm not here to
point the finger because you know you
know I support a lot of our images I
have to 250 nuns praying for me every
single day every single day I mean I do
it because I wanna you want to call it
giving back I'm calling that I'm selfish
I want to be known when they put dirt on
me as the greatest high performance
coach that ever walked the [ __ ]
planet I don't even want them to think
about Napoleon Hill only as an
afterthought and currently I am and I'm
not done yet
you know I plan on living to 100 dailies
120 I mean I be mentoring at 120 but I'm
6 foot 1 225 pounds that twisted steel
and Panther piss I'm still a formidable
guy and I don't plan on being any less
formidable during my 70s now will I be
doing this in my 80s I don't know I
don't know but the I have no outside
investments I don't do anything other
than coach the kids and why do I not
have any outside investments because
anybody that's got a portfolio that
thinks that he can devote to you kids
and over your own investments is a lie
I have no investments all I am is cash
because I never will even remotely want
to be conflicted you show me one other
person that does that I can already tell
you the are Nene what about inflation
debt what about deep layers you what
their [ __ ] as both go hunt told me
30 years ago one of the real
billionaires is
Danny if you're worried about paying
taxes you ain't making enough [ __ ]
money am I still fired up yeah and I'm
calm down too I've calmed down in my old
age and the 90s I love it cuz I beat the
kids I used it Oh God the good old days
the good old days what's next well I
love the fire and energy that you still
have for us we're wrapping up we're
almost at time it's crazy how quickly
half an hour can go for people watching
where can they learn more about you
where do you want to guide them to you
got your website you have the success
test your YouTube channel yeah thank you
for reminding me Dan video comm all the
stuffs great I've got hundreds of pages
podcast etc but if you want to separate
the men from the boys and the girls from
the women take my success test it's on
the front page your landing page and
it's only got a 95 percent accuracy rate
a correlation to you being successful
only 95 percent that's all and you take
that test and then you tell me how your
programs work up here two four and I
want to thank you ever for this
opportunity and I look forward to
hopefully seeing you when I'm in trial a
couple of universities I'm speaking in a
told me I should be concerned about my
security uh Toronto didn't tell me that
so I wouldn't worry too much about
Canadians we're usually pretty nice so I
think you have a great time I look
forward to it I look forward to me
hopefully meeting you cool well then
thank you so much to spending time with
us guys go check out Dan pina comm check
out that success test you want a little
bit more good luck on your tour Dan and
again thanks for spending a half an hour
with us today we appreciate it thank you
for the opportunity thank you very much